hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde wir befinden uns hier sehr groß
sei ihr seht es bereits im titel
eingeplant jetzt auch schon auf dem
fernseher gesehen und ihr seht auch
schon was ich hier in der hand halten
meine lieben freunde denn das ist sie
alkohol brille ecke heraus stellen und
diese brille vermittelt ein wenn man sie
aufsetzt den zustand hat wenn man
geisteskrank betrunken
wir haben hiermit schon vor einigen
jahren ein video gedreht wir haben uns
allerdings gedacht dass wir uns noch mal
an der ganzen sache probieren werden und
haben dementsprechend ein team aus
freiwilligen teilnehmern zusammen modell
die ich euch jetzt erst mal ganz kurz
vorstellen werde
lukas trägt sehr gern crocs mit socken
shari würde auch über einen wlan kabel
stolpern army würde sich ihre hosen
komplett runter ziehen nur damit man
ihren kurz besser hört lara würde ihren
kindern später als gute nacht geschichte
eine gebrauchsanweisung von einer
bohrmaschine vorlesen doro park extra
direkt neben dir um deine tür zu
blockieren caro würde sich selbst die
tür aufhalten und sich dann bedanken
greta bringt ihre eigene chili packung
mit ins restaurant leo wäscht sich seine
hände bevor er pilzen geht helin duscht
immer im badeanzug luca benutzt sein
föhn immer als mikrofon um dann vom
spiegel shirin david songs zu singen
öffnet eine packung chips mit einer
schere griff legt seinen finger an um
eine seite weiter zu blättern auf seinem
ipad selbst leidenschaftlich gern in die
dusche marx wird sich auch wenn der bus
komplett leer ist direkt neben dich
setzen und sandra die ist heute einfach
unser hindernis sage ich euch nun die
teilnehmer vorgestellt habe zeige ich
euch jetzt was wir für eine challenge
machen und zwar
dass ich nicht wenigstens zweimal
prozent das hat leider hier nahmen
gebrochen und bewegen warum hat leider
ihre schulter gebrochen und deswegen
kann sich heute nicht mitmachen schütte
hat fällt nicht mehr zusammen sind
gerissen
bei sandra sind zwei behälter gerissen
deswegen kann sich heute leider nicht
mitmachen allerdings hat sie sich
freundlicherweise dazu bereit erklärt
dass wir hier das hindernis darstellt
denn hier startet unsere challenge max
hat ein handy in der hand
beziehungsweise ich bin ja gleich hinter
der kamera allerdings muss euch jetzt
mal ganz kurz zu zeigen ich werde die
zeit stoppen dann geht es hier los
ich habe die brille auf man musste
dreimal um sandra rumspringt frei
natürlich mit brille aufhabe ich will
erfolg damit schon mal weiß und ein
drittes mal
dann läuft man ja dass man jetzt vier
dann an sandra vor bei zumwalde
gefahrene die gerüchte behaupten und
dann wird die zeit gestoppt wenn man das
tor trifft werden fünf sekunden von
derzeit abgezogen werde niemandem die
zeit sagen und am ende stehen alle in
einer reihe haben die augen zu der
verlierer der die längste zeit hatte
bekommt von mir einmal wasser
überschüttet 321 co
und jetzt absolut haben sie lasse
absolute und abzubauen
joop habe ich bin gar nicht angefeuert
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
1 und nummer 2 und nummer 3 an die latte
und stoppt das hier geboren hier leider
auch nicht dass vorgestoßen sind meine
damen und herren erste umdrehung 2003 an
besonderen gebrochenen schulter und
absolute absolut absurd und laut ist und
auf den kreuzungen laufen und schoss
erst umdrehen und sobald 12 und absolute
absolute oder auch daneben aber das hier
ist sebastian
[Applaus]
letztere hat zumal hat zum ball
bald wird das das erste tor
[Applaus]
[Musik]
dr
ja
[Musik]
[Applaus]
freydank
12 und hat so latte herrschen sehr schön
sehr schön langsam sputen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
man muss überlegen leo hat einen
meniskusriss und trotzdem das absolute
absolute und jetzt ab zum ball
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ich habe schon nicht ob ich das aus und
vorbei
beliebt
weil die zeit die ich mit mir weiter
dreht sich erste drehen geist tempo drin
ist so das ist die zeit das hier ist
jetzt das finale ranking von daher seht
ihr auch direkt das famila den letzten
platz belegt hat luca bereitet den eimer
für die bestrafung frau mit eiskaltem
wasser
dank alter jetzt bist du wer aber der
verlierer als erfahrt ihr wenn ihr jetzt
erstmal alle die augen zumacht das video
einen kanal abonniert ich zähle unter
der maxime darunter weiß und wissen wir
wo ich mich hin bewegen